hey how's it going everyone can everyone
hear me yeah oh great okay
so uh wow it's great to talk um a little
bit about myself I wrote a book automate
the boring stuff with Python so back in
about 2012 I'm not sure if other people
have a similar memory but I'd say it was
around 2012 when learned to code became
this huge meme of sorts and everybody
was sort of like getting really excited
about code Academy and everybody was
sort of thinking oh I should learn how
to code and learn how to program and you
know was this exciting new skill that
everybody should get like everybody
should learn how to program and so I
sort of thought well why exactly
I mean why I learned to code as opposed
to I don't know learn to speak Spanish
or learn how to operate a table saw or
something and and I feel like a lot of
people who aren't software developers
have this sort of anxiety that they
don't want to get left behind as
technology changes so learning to code
is is sort of a way that they could you
know get ahead of that curve but it
really sort of bothered me because it
seemed to be more of a fad and
especially the idea that everybody
should learn how to code I was wondering
how that was and so I thought about and
I kind of came around to the conclusion
like yeah you know pretty much everybody
should learn how to code not everyone
has to become a software engineer I mean
that's that's kind of crazy you need
lots of different types of people to
make world but learning how to code is
is sort of like a generally useful skill
to have and so I sort of thought well
what types of things should people learn
how to do and and I kind of considered
what would the average office worker who
or somebody who uses a computer as part
of their day-to-day work what type of
skills would they have to learn and so I
compiled a whole bunch of this together
and and thought Python was a great
language to use as a beginners
programming language like the first
language that you learn and I wrote a
book and it's called automate the boring
stuff with Python it's released under a
Creative Commons license can everyone
see my screen right now as well okay so
yeah so you can read the entire book at
automate the boring stuff dot-com so
tonight I'm gonna be going over Chapter
12 which is the chapter where you're
working with Excel spreadsheets but I
just sort of thought like okay well you
know those types of things that office
workers need to learn how to automate
with their computer and so just you know
like reading and writing files and
regular expressions when scraping or
just you know parsing a whole bunch of
PDF files because I would have a lot of
friends who had office jobs who would
say something like you know I spent
three hours today just like opening a
spreadsheet up and copying and pasting
this one line into a different
spreadsheet and then opening the next
spreadsheet and this really like tedious
mind-numbing task that if they knew how
to program they'd be able to automate it
so I think the the most popular chapters
in this book are the web scraping and
the GUI automation and the excel
chapters so I'm just gonna go through
the Excel stuff tonight so the I had to
look through a whole bunch of different
Python modules when I was compiling this
book together and the best module that I
found for excel is one called open pi
excel and it has a really nice read the
docs page it's it's pretty well
maintained it's up-to-date it has a lot
of nice features it doesn't have every
single feature that you could possibly
want but it has all of the big ones and
so I'm just gonna sort of lightly go
through this over the main features
tonight and just sort of live coding
exercises because what could possibly go
wrong with live coding exercises so the
way to install open PI Excel is you can
just use pip so something like you know
pip install open PI Excel is hopefully
the easy way to get it installed on your
machine I think the latest version is
two point three point five I believe but
once you have it installed on your
laptop then it's really easy to get
started I'm just gonna be using idle for
all of this just because you know it's
the thing that most people probably have
already installed and configured but
open PI Excel and let's see what the
latest version is by yeah under version
dunder 2.3.4 okey I think I have a
slightly older version they've made some
changes in in the API but I think a lot
of the times they have like nice
warnings that tell you like okay this
name has been changed to whatever yeah
so we just here's an example spreadsheet
that I have that I'm gonna be using I
just have some random data date times
strings numbers
the thing about spreadsheets is that you
can sort of consider this to be the same
thing as like a Cartesian coordinate
system with data at each of these cells
so instead of x and y they have columns
and rows and the columns have letters
and then you know each coordinate you
can find some piece of information some
piece of data that you want to
manipulate and open PI Excel does a
really good job of making this easy to
use I'm going to first change my working
directory let's see to my desktop and so
the now there are some like weird little
warts in open pie Excel I think the
first one is that it doesn't have an
open function as like the obvious name
for the open function but instead it has
load workbook and then you just pass it
the file name that you want so open
let's see excelled SX and you can see
here's that workbook object which is the
name of the the spreadsheet file itself
and see they got very specific here with
workbook workbook dot workbook just in
case you forget what type of file it is
so that represents this excel file and
you know I never really messed around
with Excel all that much I always just
thought it was like okay here's the one
spreadsheet but actually workbooks
contain multiple spreadsheets you see
this in the tabs down here and oh and by
the way I'm using Excel but since the
file formats are the same for libre
office and OpenOffice you can use those
spreadsheet programs as well to read
your files but you can see that there's
you know multiple sheets inside of a
single workbook so if we want to
actually grab one of those sheets we can
just call the get sheet names method
just to see what's in there and by
default Excel usually puts in sheet 1
sheet 2 sheet 3 I'm just gonna grab one
of those sheets with get sheet by name I
don't want to go too much into just you
know do being a reference manual of
sorts and going through a laundry list
of all the different functions that are
that are in this module but I just want
to give you sort of a general tour of
what open pi excel can do there we go
and look at this this is a worksheet
object and here is where you have you
can use pythons brackets indexing to
actually grab the values in each of
these cells let's go for a one you can
get it see this value
it's a date/time object and so open PI
Excel will create a date/time object for
that and look at strings you can see
that's returned as a string and then
also if you have these formatted as
numbers in your spreadsheet open Pi
Excel you can see this is returned as an
integer rather than a string of the
number 73 so this is kind of nice you
can sort of conceptually think of your
spreadsheet as just this Cartesian
coordinate sort of two-dimensional data
structure just like if you had some sort
of like list of Lists
sort of object or if you had say I don't
know a dictionary where the x and y
coordinates were restored as a
- energy sure to polls the exact same
sort of concept here this is just your
file is just a 2-dimensional data
structure and opened by excel is has
made some pretty good choices for most
of its naming concepts like if you
wanted to update say this number 73 in
your spreadsheet you can just take that
value and let's just change this to 42
and right now this is all stored just in
memory right now if you want to save it
to disk and take that original workbook
object that you had and call save and I
usually save this as a different file
name just so I don't overwrite my
original file I'm always paranoid about
if I write some script it might have a
bug on it some bug in it that I just
like run it over an entire folder of all
these spreadsheets and that just
completely mangles all my data so I'm
just gonna be saving this as a different
file that's just with the dot save
function so I'm just gonna go back to my
desktop open this up and now you can see
this has changed to 42
so really obvious right let's see
there's there's a whole bunch of other
bells and whistles that open Pi Excel
gives you for example you can take a
look at the individual sheets and you
can see that it has a title I can maybe
change that to a new name if I wanted to
go ahead and save that again example 3
[Music]
and now you can see down here it's named
my sheet name instead of just sheet 1
and yeah so okay so that's a pretty
obvious way to access these files but
using this you know sort of a string of
c1 or some other name for the cell is
kind of awkward especially if you're
gonna write a for loop and just iterate
over several different values that you
have so fortunately fortunately open PI
a excel has some ways of making this a
little bit easier
let's see sheet also has a cell function
where you can retrieve a specific cell
so if I wanted to grab say row 1 column
3 column 3 is you know using integers as
much nicer than just using letters of
the alphabet right here that returns
that exact same cell object this does so
you can just call dot value on that and
then read the value that way this way
you can have something you know like for
range in let's just say five row is I
column is three
oh haha this is a new I would at least
have a few errors during any live coding
demo so oh another important thing that
you might have been wondering about is
that all of these the indexes start at
one and not zero which sort of makes
sense if you're coming from the Excel
world
I mean you write here the row the first
row is Row one not row zero so I'm gonna
have to change this just a little bit
gonna have to start at one and then go
to five you can see it'll spit out all
of those numbers right here they're the
same numbers here well I changed the
first one but you can see 85 1452 now if
you just want to find out well how many
rows or how many columns you have in
that sheet this is stored as just a
simple attribute we can find the max row
just seven you can see that's the very
last row that has information stored to
it and max column which is returned as
an integer which is three so you can see
the C column is the latest one and
switching between the the column names
with letters back to integers is sort of
a pain and you could write your own
function to do it but fortunately open
Pi Excel provides that for us it is
let's see open pi x l dot cell dot get
column letter
and then you can pass this something
like the number one and that returns a
or the number 26 and that returns e and
with Excel if you've ever created a
super big spreadsheet once you get past
see it just adds another letter sort of
making this like a base 26 number system
so 27 is just a a and then it goes on to
a BAC and we also have the exact the
inverse of that where if you wanted to
what is it get the believe it's get
column index from string we had
something like oh no I think it is just
get column index from string that'll do
the inverse where it just takes the
letters that you're providing it with
and then it returns the number but
really using this I find myself most
often just using this sheet dot cell and
then passing it the row and column
numbers directly whenever I have to
iterate over a whole range of different
values yeah so that's essentially all
you have to all you need to know really
if you want to treat an Excel
spreadsheet as just sort of this
two-dimensional data structure but a lot
of people like to use all of the really
fancy options of Excel like you know
people fall in love with their
spreadsheets and want to make the data
look nicer they were gonna use better
fonts or different sizing for the rows
and columns and open-plan Excel also
lets you do that as well this is really
a really nice feature to have if you
ever need to generate Excel spreadsheets
for like a daily report where you just
need to create a nicely formatted
spreadsheet file that has a whole bunch
of numbers on it and you're generating
this on a day to day basis but you want
you still want to look nice and not just
like a spreadsheet full of numbers so
let's going back to that workbook object
if we wanted to ever create new sheets
here instead of just sheet 1 sheet 2
sheet 3 we have our create sheet
function for the creat sheet method for
the workbook
we can give it any title you know my
sheet name like I did before and we can
also give it its position inside the
workbook so you can see sheet 1 is the
first sheet I wanted my sheet name to be
the new first sheet in this workbook I
could just give it an index of 0 for
what I did to be the second one I could
just give it an index of 1 I'll go ahead
and try saving this and opening that up
oh yeah and here's that old one that
when I changed it to my sheet name and
now that I've given it a duplicate name
same as the original one Excel will just
automatically add one to its name so you
can add additional sheets to it you can
also change the sizes of these of these
individual cells I'll go back here we
just have the sheet object we'll just
find it's row dimensions and we can say
Oh take the row dimensions of Row 1 we
can find out I guess it doesn't give us
the the height of it but we can assign
the height be something like super tall
we can do this the same thing with the
column dimensions let's say column 2 I
want to be really wide oh that's an
unfortunate error oh right
columns in this case we're not going to
be able to use integers for for the
comes but we'll have to use something
like column B instead of column 2 we can
adjust the width of that and I'll just
save this
[Music]
that's a really odd air huh okay well I
knew I was playing with fire by having a
live coding demo which was of course
working half and how her ago but yes so
it is possible at least to change the
column names or the column dimensions
and the row dimensions as well just if
you want to ever space these out
differently from something besides their
default values and then you can also
change around the the height and width
as well just go ahead and reload that
workbook so let's take let's see get
sheet name Oh get sheet by name let's
see um oh right and also if you ever
wanted to change the font style just
give it a different font and with a
different size maybe bolded or
underlined if you ever want to create
sort of a heading for the first row you
can take like an individual cell let me
just try b1 and I can set this to a
brand-new font object now Oh fonts have
a really long name so usually I'm just
gonna do something like from open PI
Excel dot styles in court font
I can take that be one cell and set its
font to a brand new font so I can just
you can see all the options right here
just say maybe I want to make it size
fourteen set bold to true set italic to
true and then I'll save this as a new
file and so you can make adjustments to
the individual fonts as well so that's
all the the basic sort of data
manipulation mod functionality of open
pi excel you can also you know make it
kind of look really nice the main thing
that people really like about excel
though is being able to create graphs
easily from data and this is where open
PI Excel is is really nice but it's it's
you know it's still an open source
project that's maintained by two people
so it does have the ability to create
charts from your data of an existing
spreadsheet that has that already has a
chart loaded it's not going to be able
to read that chart in and make any
adjustments to it but again if you have
something like a daily report that
you're creating then being able to
create a chart inside these inside these
spreadsheets programmatically it's a
really nice feature to have
unfortunately it's also kind of a very
lengthy setup and I always have to
consult the reference materials to
remember how to do all the different
steps so I'm gonna go through this
hopefully this will work out really
nicely
so we're just going to so we have our
basic importing open PI Excel I'm just
going to get that workbook object again
or actually or if you want to create a
brand new workbook object and just call
open PI Excel workbook
[Music]
now unless they've changed out
fortunately I think in this new version
[Music]
they have named this two workbook with a
capital W okay we'll just create a new
sheet for that and let's just populate
it with some random data I'm just going
to import random right here make a quick
loop starting from one because the the
beginning row index is 1 and not 0 we'll
just go up to 11 and I don't know maybe
I'll just have sheet a whichever so
column a and I'll just set the value of
that some random data right here
something from one to a hundred
okay let me save this and just check
that this is working out hmm oh it's
it's what oh yes
me open that up oh right
okay there we go yes thank you very much
okay so now we have some random data
here I'll go back to to idle
okay so creating a chart that's don't X
I don't expect anyone to remember all
these different steps but I just want to
quickly go through them just to show you
that it is possible first you're gonna
create a series object or a reference
object
[Music]
and this will just have a sort of which
cells in your spreadsheet that you want
to create data out of so I'm just gonna
go from that a one cell down to a ten oh
[Music]
this is chart I believe now oh okay hold
on I think I have Oh rats okay I think I
have the wrong I'm sorry about this I
have the wrong version of open PI Excel
installed and they've made a lot of
adjustments in this area okay so I'm not
going to do the thing where I'm gonna
have the entire audience bear with me
while I go through all of this but it is
possible to create bar charts or line
charts using open pi excel so that you
can generate charts inside these
spreadsheets programmatically yeah so
again as I said before open Pi Excel
it's it's the most mature Python module
for dealing with Excel spreadsheets
that's currently out there there were a
few others that I found but none of them
were anywhere near as you know feature
full as open pi excel so I really sing
the praises of this project and they can
definitely use much more help if you
have the time they have a bitbucket
repo that you can check out but also um
you know because Excel spreadsheets sort
of have this I don't know it's so really
complicated and wonderful but
complicated piece of software that has a
lot of different features and so a lot
of you might think that working on a
module that could deal with something so
complex but really it's not quite that
bad and I mean if you take any of these
excel I don't know if you know this but
you take any excel file and just change
it to dot zip all of these excel files
are
actually just zip files I'll close this
first I have this one so all of these
Excel files are really just zip files
that themselves just contain a lot of
XML files and other human readable files
so it's really easy just to get started
just you know taking a look poking
around at the different files and the
XML the the format for these files is
actually fairly well-documented so if
you're looking for an open source
project to get involved with I really
recommend using open pi excel as well so
yeah the the rest of I don't want to go
taking up too much more time but there's
a lot of other features for pi open pi
excel that I cover in the book automate
the boring stuff and again you can find
this online in full for free under a
Creative Commons license at automate the
boring stuff comm yeah thank you very
much and I can take mine any questions
that people have
all right if you guys have questions
please contact the mic so that al can
hear you and we can give you guys
someone's approaching the mic now as we
speak al yeah okay hello I was wondering
if open PI Excel can handle formulas in
Excel it can right now it can't if you
have a formula that will evaluate to
some data based on the other information
in the Excel spreadsheet open PI Excel
won't be able to do that evaluation but
you can store you can create your own
formulas by just assigning it the exact
same way you would in Excel so I'll just
go to one of these spreadsheets say if
right here I wanted to add something
like equals sum from c1 to what c7 and
then it just shows this as the total of
these cells right here so open PI Excel
you won't be able to get this 466 number
from it but you will be able to create
the formula just by assigning this value
to that to that cells as that cells
value so I would have something like
sheet c8 dot value would be equal to
that and then once you save this and
when you open it up in Excel you'd be
able to it would it would look exactly
like this so yeah unfortunately you
can't be able to evaluate these for
these Excel formulas inside of open pie
XL yet that's not a feature that they
have
the presentation I have a two-part
question the first part is does open
pyre sell recognize the sell objects
like the sell table and then the second
question is can you access the
underlying sell data model that became
available in a Cell 2016 via open pi yes
sir so for the first part I believe you
can't just there are a lot of features
that open PI excel has kind of like
charts where you can create charts
inside of new or existing spreadsheets
but if your spreadsheet file hat already
has something like a chart or a table in
it then it when you load it inside of
open pie Excel it'll just completely not
yeah I guess that information just isn't
parsed and returned in your workbook
object so tables I believe it doesn't
have you really just have access to sort
of the primitive data types right here
and what was your second question there
was a there was a
compared to the oh I'm sorry I went to
sit down to listen to your response the
second part in Excel 2016 I think it
started in Excel 2013 Microsoft made
available a data model that is actually
like a database type schema that's
available in a Cell that you can use
PowerPivot and things like that to query
against Oh use it's highly compressed it
allows you to store a lot of data within
a cell that's highly compressible I
think it's up to 10 times the
compression rate so with that that
allows you to do a lot of things in the
cell that traditionally you weren't able
to do right yeah currently open Pi Excel
doesn't doesn't support that
unfortunately there are a lot of lot of
things a lot of really advanced features
of Excel so if you're really into Excel
that open Pi Excel doesn't have yet
really what open pi Excel is really
great at is just being able to read in
basic data types and also just you
generate Excel spreadsheet files but
unfortunately it doesn't support that
feature yet are you familiar with a
pistol it's a tool developed by I
believe in thought um I think I've heard
of it before but I'm not sure I'm really
familiar with it okay thanks
okay hi open Excel have an SQL interface
where you can write an SQL query and
have it return a data set unfortunately
no it's it's sort of like you something
you've treated like as a dictionary
where these individuals cell locations
are sort of the keys and the data inside
that cell is the value so it's right now
it's sort of just at the very primitive
level of sort of a key value pair store
how familiar or how friendly is opened
by excel with multi-user aspects of
Excel such that two people could be in a
spreadsheet at the same time
Oh currently it doesn't support that
it's it's sort of just treating the
spreadsheet file as in individual sort
of like any other flat file that you
just open and load in and then save any
changes to so right now there's nothing
that you can sort of you can't really
make a connection to a spreadsheet file
that other people would be manipulating
at the same time constraints around the
size of Excel spreadsheet you can make
mean do they slow down considerably once
you get past a certain number or columns
um I don't believe so I mean I've done
some testing in this regard and I've
been able to create spreadsheets with I
believe like something on the order of
like tens of thousands of rows with you
know several columns of data but as far
as going you know sort of into the
gigabyte range of that I haven't really
worked with with spreadsheet files that
size um
theoretically it's it's something that I
think open pi excel should be able to
handle I mean I've never noticed at any
sort of slowdowns at any size before but
I haven't really tested sort of beyond
you know tens on the order of magnitude
of tens of thousands so for a lot of the
people are there's a couple people here
who are here specifically for the excel
aspect and I was curious to maybe some
practical practical examples of maybe
people you've spoken to that really
leveraged this to make their life's
better I mean obviously in the book so
you know read the books online but
anything specific that stands out to you
that you'd like to share about that yeah
actually um sort of before I wrote this
book and it was just an idea in my head
I went to a place on meet up here in San
Francisco and I was talking with one
person who wasn't a software developer
they had just taught themselves a little
bit of Python and part of their job was
to I think goaded like the Yahoo
finance page and copy a whole bunch of
numbers from there
plug them into Excel and they had to do
this every day to generate report their
boss and he wasn't using pi excel at the
time I think he was just using CSV files
but he had taught himself enough
programming to be able to generate these
files instantaneously the you know just
the script would do some web scraping
grab those numbers put them inside of an
Excel spreadsheet and then he could just
email that off to his boss and he's it's
just sort of you took something that
would usually eat up about 45 minutes or
an hour of his day every day and you
know took him several hours to be able
to learn enough to write this script but
he would then be able to sort of
generate these files all the time and so
really I I think a lot of the types of
programming that you know for non
software developers who want to learn
how to code though a lot of types of
tasks that they can automate are sort of
pulling data from one source and then
being able to put data into some other
format or also while doing some cleanup
of the data so whether that data is on a
website that you have to do some web
scraping or if it's in a flat text file
or if it's in a database that you want
to make a connection to and then just do
some cleaning of that data and then
packaging up in some other into some
other files such as an Excel spreadsheet
that's something that really helped them
out there was also you know I'm not
exactly I'm not a super proficient with
Excel but there was one test case that I
had once come up with I created an
example of that here where say I have
some sort of spreadsheet right here just
shows you know produce sales have
something really simple like what the
prices of some piece of produce and how
many pounds were sold of that and then
it has a very simple formula right here
I had one case where I had you know
spreadsheets sort of like this and I
wanted to update the cost of let's say
you know you wanted to update the cost
of potatoes here
you know normally you can just do a
simple Find and Replace for
you know find where her 86 cents is in
his file and then update it elsewhere
but the file that I was working with was
super huge and I couldn't be sure that
potatoes were the only thing that were
you know 86 cents in costs and so I
didn't want to inadvertently change the
data of some other type of thing either
but I didn't really know if there was
some way of being able to find like okay
I want to find 0.86
and change all and do a find and replace
on all of those cells but I also want to
only do that if the cell to the left of
that says potatoes and then I also had
several other items that I wanted to
update the cost of and so here is where
if I could just you know I know how to
do this in Python already so I can just
write a quick script to do it but I just
needed to figure out a way of how I
could open up an entire spreadsheet and
just use it the same way I would use a
dictionary or a list of lists or some
other you know pythonic data structure
and then be able to save that so that's
sort of the one of the tests that I
found that you know using something like
open pi excel to open it up really
helped me out just because otherwise I
would have to just do a finder in
replace but I would have to visually
inspect each time to make sure I'm not
changing I'm only changing the things I
want to change and nothing else so
that's sort of one example that that I
have just from my own workings with with
writing you know quick Python scripts to
to modify spreadsheets
Kayal this is writer Timberlake I'm a
big fan
I would love to dig deeper and to
automate the boring stuff with Python in
the future I'm actually using your
command loop from your text RPG tutorial
oh well in a friend's game of porting
from adrift anyway the question I wanted
to ask you so do you do a lot of these
automation things in your day-to-day do
you automate a lot of your daily tasks I
do and really you know I never really
thought of it as automating things but
it was sort of like if there was ever a
chance where I could
a small script to pull a bunch of data
or especially if I ever found myself
where I'm doing something where I'm like
highlighting some sentence and then
copying and pasting it into a different
thing yeah even if writing the script
would take probably just as long as
doing it by hand sort of the I would
free myself from such mental strain of
just having to sit there and you know
doing this mindless task that's really
boring
it was super helpful if for something
like that
I think the the other two the main ones
I do are also the two chapters that are
really popular in in automate and that
is one is web scraping where if I wanted
to just pull information from a website
or just say like follow a bunch of links
and download images from each page or
download files from different links and
then you know click on the next link
programmatically and once that page
loads up then download that file and
click the next link and download the
next file that helped out a lot and also
the other chapter is the GUI automation
chapter where essentially you can write
a script that can control the mouse and
keyboard for you because a lot of times
you'll run into situations where you
have to deal with software that doesn't
have a public API and there is really no
way to automate it you know something
like you know Photoshop has batch
automated processing where you can
record a whole bunch of steps and then
play them out on eat every image inside
of a file inside of a file but most
software doesn't have anything like that
but you know they do have a graphical
user interface and so if you can just
sort of write a script that will just
you know click here then click here then
click here type this out and then click
Submit and then just do that over and
over again writing the script really
saves you just a lot of hassle of just
having to you know sit down and do this
task for an hour or two at a time so
it's really saved me you know a lot of
time in that aspect awesome
thank you you're speaking of my follow
up question which I'm just gonna sort of
mumble here because I don't want to take
a we you know we don't want to take up
much more your time I think I'm glancing
over at Calvin
I say that but so what I wanted to ask
was what the main most useful automation
that you've done for yourself has been
in terms of productivity would it be
like GUI or I think so
I mean one of the problems I have
whenever I try to come up with examples
I'm like oh I wrote a script to do this
it's it's usually something where you
know I'm writing a software tool that
helps me write other software so that's
not really something that you know non
engine is software engineers would
really find useful but yeah when it
comes to just sort of like the types of
tasks that other people might use I
think probably GUI automation web
scraping were really big ones let's see
actually uh so no starch press which
published automate the boring stuff one
of the employees there actually read
through the book and wrote a small
script that would just go to Amazon's
website and then for each one of their
titles just download a whole bunch of
Amazon ranked information so they could
then just create graphs overtime of like
hell the ranks of their different titles
we're doing on Amazon on a day to day
basis you know that's something that you
know you can get an intern to do but
that's you know really tedious to just
open a web browser copy and paste all
that information so yeah it's learning
to code in order to write these sort of
one-off scripts is really helpful and
it's it's at the same time it's hard for
me to come up with a particular examples
because it's so custom to your own
personal workflow or how your
organization is set up or how you have
your files organized because you know
for most common tasks there's commercial
software already written you know if you
want to put information into a
spreadsheet you have Excel if you want
to write up a document you have all
sorts word processing software and
there's there's software for doing like
master renaming of files but you know if
you had some particular
a task that's really specific to your
own thing you're kind of left with
either doing it by hand or I don't know
maybe hiring a software developer which
it's usually gonna be really expensive
and not really worth the money but by
just learning how to code you know not
enough to become a software engineer at
Google or Facebook or anything like that
but just being a little learned enough
code to be able to write a quick script
to automate some really otherwise
brain-dead tasks is a pretty valuable
skill to have thank you very much
no thank you was fairly rudimentary and
it's Excel manipulation and couldn't do
a lot of the advanced features have you
played with GUI automation at all to see
if you how much of that stuff you could
automate I have so there is one product
called
I believe school II which is its own
sort of a piece of software it has its
own editor and creates its own language
a lot of people seem to really like that
on Windows there's something called
autohotkey which again creates its own
scripting language and it's kind of nice
to work with but these are both sort of
weird because they sort of I don't know
for one you have to sort of learn those
systems and I was looking for something
really straightforward I actually ended
up writing a new module called PI
auto-pilot of GUI and let's see that's
in chapter 18 right here
but essentially PI auto GUI I'll just
load up the read the docs page for it
Ayana GUI was different from all the
other GUI automation modules for Python
I found because I wanted something that
worked with Python two and three and
also worked on Windows Mac and Linux so
a lot of the tools that I found on pi PI
which just sort of be Windows only or
Python 2 only or something like that so
I was able to sort of stand on the
shoulders of giants by by looking at
their code and seeing how they did
things and I wanted to create a really
dead simple eight API so I think I might
have it loaded here so PI auto GUI I
tried to make it a really sort of
straightforward API so if you know
wanted to click the mouse somewhere I
can just pass it XY coordinates on your
screen and so you can see the mouse
instantly has moved up here I believe
this version has a few enable user
access control on Windows you sometimes
get errors but it will still perform the
action or it's something like pile GUI
if you want to type out a string being
can see it's instantly typed that out
right here that wasn't printed or
returned from this function and so this
was sort of another another really handy
thing that I developed and enough so I
have actually became my most popular
open-source project that I've ever
published people really seem to respond
well well to this just having something
that was easy to use and fairly
straightforward I mean so theoretically
you could use something like that if you
just had Excel open upon on your
computer and you could say like oh I
want to click here and then click on
this and then click on this and then
type in this number right here there are
some downsides with that I gave a talk
at Jango Khan and high-bay more recently
sort of covering what the PI auto GUI
module could do and so you can check
that out if you want yeah so yeah so two
years ago I left my job to write books
full time and and finish up automate and
then after that I worked with no search
press on a book called Scratch
programming playground
there's a tool from MIT called scratch
which is sort of like a combination of
the logo programming thing where you
have a turtle that you can you know tell
to move forward and turn right 90
degrees and it draws out sort of
spirograph
lines behind it and you can program it
to do all sorts of neat little things
scratch is sort of like that plus
several other things and it's a great
programming tool for for kids and
beginners and so I have a book coming
out from no starch press actually in a
couple weeks it's been under development
and now it's finally coming out and I
had other book ideas I really welcome
any sort of an advice on this one idea
was sort of like writing in-house tools
in Python sort of extending what
automate would do and said you know
instead of writing small scripts just
writing small applications that you know
again you if there's off-the-shelf
commercial software for that's great but
if you want something very particular to
your organization or your personal
workflow you know just enough
programming to be able to write
something like that oh and then the the
the main book idea I had is automating
these robots in Minecraft there's a
minecraft mod that adds these sort of
little robots that you can program in
Lua unfortunately not Python but you can
actually just write a small Lua script
that will program them to move around
the Minecraft world and I saw like oh
this is great because so many so many
kids I know and probably a lot of adults
too just absolutely love Minecraft and
so that was sort of another book up
project idea but yeah everybody can can
contact me probably Twitter is the best
way to contact me so I'm just at Alice
white my name right there or just
sending me an email at Al at invent with
Python calm
but yeah I'm open to any more questions
if anybody else has them it would have
actually really helped out a lot of
while ago when I was working on a
project bridge basically take it's
fairly simple and practical spreadsheet
and enter them into a form on a
FileMaker Pro database yeah
horribly convoluted if people don't
build them well yes difficult but
unfortunately I wasn't aware of Paiute
Auto GUI at the time so if say I had the
spreadsheet I could just take the data
into the cells exactly since it'll
actually take a snapshot if you provided
with a PNG image it can find that on the
screen for you I've been using a name of
it right now there's a good open source
like screenshot tool that I was using
are you so if say somebody wanted to
fork PI auto GUI to kind of extend it a
little bit more to make kind of managing
all the snapshots and stuff easier oh
yeah definitely I mean I have PI auto
GUI available on github and just type up
I'm just Alice why Girt on actually now
I'm a Swaggart on github and so you can
find the the peyote GUI repo right there
I'm also accepting a pull request all
the time I don't have a lot of time to
devote to PI auto GUI but I try to stay
up on at least you know acknowledging
all the bug reports that I get you can
imagine there's all sorts of weird
issues that you know being available on
Windows Mac and Linux
having piled a GUI run on you know I had
one person say like oh this doesn't work
with my french keyboard and so you know
sort of situations I never really
considered or ran into myself but yeah
oh and going back to to what you were
saying earlier yeah I mean I'm sure that
there's probably some way to like with
FileMaker Pro be able to like come
programmatically just convert data from
an Excel spreadsheet to FileMaker Pro
but a lot of times it's often just
easier to use some sort of GUI
automation tool that just you know plugs
in number all your data by mimicking the
keyboard and then just entering it that
way yeah so I can I can definitely see
that there's also sort of I think a lot
of people tell me whenever they have to
deal with sort of enterprise software
those notoriously have atrocious user
interfaces one guy I was talking to said
like every day when he logs into his
system at work there is some like list
of domains that he uh that you know if
you want to access yes to check these
and so there's 20 check boxes that he
has to just check every day you know it
takes 30 seconds to do this but it's it
got to the point where he was so sick of
doing that all the time he just wrote a
small script that would then just find
the check boxes and do all that checking
for him so all he has to do is just run
this script and have it do that small
little task for him again it's something
really particular to his own set up that
you know you'll never find some
commercial software from Microsoft you
know like check box clicker 2.0 or
something like that so be able to write
your own code to do you know automate
these little tests like this is really
helpful thank you very much oh yeah
thank you
oh um actually if you would allow me to
give you the 30-second version of a
5-minute lightning talk that I gave at
PI Bay these Python meetups are really
great so I gave it a talk at lightning
talk at PI Bay where I basically said
you know all of these presentations you
can learn a lot from them but for the
most part you can just sort of ditch all
of these presentations the most
important thing about coming to a
meet-up
these Python meetups is meeting other
people so even if that involves you know
just skipping out on the presentation
it's fine they're all recorded and you
can look them up online if you ever want
that information but go ahead and be
sure to go out and you know say hello to
the other humans that are in this room
exchange business cards get email
addresses follow up with them it's a
really wonderful opportunity that you
don't want to miss and be sure to come
back to these Python meetups and just
you know say hi and maintain those
connections but um yes thank you very
much for having me it was great Chris of
presenting here I could not agree more
why don't you give a big round of
applause and thank you both so much for
joining us here in Indianapolis from the
west coast
[Applause]